بعد اربعه ايام فقط من بدء الحرب على
اوكرانيا سارعت موسكو وكياف الى الجلوس
وجها لوجه على طاوله المفاوضات في
بيلاروسيا لكن الجولات الخمسه التي عقدت
هناك انتهت دون تحقيق تقدم يمكن الركود
اليه باستثناء تفاهمات على فتح ممرات
انسانيه تسمح بخروج المدنيين من اتون
المعارك لكن اكثر المحاولات المعلنه جديه
كانت تلك التي استضافتها تركيا حيث التقى
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
نظيره الاوكراني ديمتروكوليبا بحضور
الوسيط التركي مولود شاوج اوغلو فكان ذلك
الاجتماع ارفع تواصل علني بين الجانبين
منذ بدايه الحرب
لعبت تركيا دورا محوريا في تقريب وجهات
النظر مستنده الى علاقاتها الوثيقه بطرفي
الحرب واستطاعت جمع وفدي البلدين لكنها لم
توفق في الخروج باتفاق ينهي الحرب
غير انها استطاعت انجاز ما عرف باتفاق
الحبوب الذي اتاح تصدير ملايين الاطنان من
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود وهو
ما جنب العلم ازمه غذائيه حاده ومنذ ذلك
الوقت جرى الحديث عن جهود دبلوماسيه لوضع
قطار التفاوض على سكته مره اخرى لكن هذه
المحاولات جرت في ظل نزال عسكري كان كل
طرف فيه يرفع شروط التفاوض في كل مره احرز
فيها كسبا عسكريا على الارض
الجانب الاوكراني الذي حقق مكاسب عسكريه
مهمه كبحت التقدم الروسي على طول الجبهه
حضر على نفسه التفاوض مع الرئيس بوتين
طالما هو في موقع الرئاسه ووضع مزيدا من
الخطوط الحمراء اقلها استعاده كامل
السياده في المقابل رفعت موسكو سقف خطوطها
الحمراء لاسيما بعد ضمها اربع مناطق في
شرق اوكرانيا بحيث اصبحت جزءا من اراضي
الاتحاد الروسي لا يمكن التنازل عنه وفق
دستورها الوطني في روسيا من بات يؤكد ان
الحديث عن الخطوط الحمراء بات من الماضي
والا رجوع عن تحقيق كامل اهداف العمليه
العسكريه هذا في وقت تترسخ ولد الغرب
قناعه بان دعمه العسكريه لاوكرانيا لابد
منه لجر موسكو الى التفاوض على الاقل
والحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بها في نهايه
المطاف